[موسيقى]
اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا
في يوم الثلاثاء
24 اكتوبر 2017
كنت جالسا في احدى غرف الدراسه
لمركزي هيلي فاميلي الطلابي هي الافلام
في جامعه الرائعه جامعه جورج تاون
في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن دي سي
[موسيقى]
من اعضاء مجتمع جورج تاون الذين كانوا
يذهبون الى هناك للبحث والقراءه والكتابه
والاطلاع او حتى الاستغلال الشاشات الضخمه
في هذا المركز لمتابعه الجديد في الرياضه
والسياسه ايضا كانت تدور الكثير من
النقاشات هناك
خصوصا حول حاله الحروب الثقافيه التي بدا
يزداد اشتعالها في الولايات المتحده منذ
ذلك الوقت
وبالطبع النقاشات في مدينه مثل واشنطن
ديسي غالبا ما تكون نقاشات ساخنه جدا فهذه
مدينه
تقع على مفترق الطرق بين الاعلام
والسياسه بين
الاكاديمياكس او مراكز الفكر وبين
الدبلوماسيه
والمراكز الثقافيه والفنيه العالميه
ولكن في ذلك اليوم
24 اكتوبر 2017
لم تكن لتلف انتباهي تلك الشاشات الضخمه
في فاميلي
ولم اكن لاهتم بالحاله الامريكيه باكملها
فقد كانت عينايا مسمرتين على شاشه صغيره
لجهاز ماك بوك الخاص بي بينما كانت اذنايا
تنصتان بمزيج من الاعجاب والدهشه
والانبهار الى كلمات
تعلن للعالم
عن اطلاق المشروع السعودي الطموح وغير
المسبوق الذي اطلق عليه اسم
[تصفيق]
كل ما في اعلاني اليوم كان مدهشا وجذابا
ومميزا ولكن ربما لكوني كائنا لغويا
بالدرجه الاولى بدات اركز اكثر في اسم
المشروع فهذا الاسم يتكون من جزئين نيو
وترمز الى كلمه جديد في اللغه الاغريقيه
وبعض اللغات الغربيه اليوم
والجزء الثاني وهو حرف الميم والذي يرمز
الى كلمه مستقبل باللغه العربيه فبالتالي
كانت نيوم هي المستقبل الجديد
بهذا يتجاوز الاسم في خصائصه اللغويه او
هكذا قراته ثنائيه الشرق والغرب ليكون
الاسم الانسب لهذا المشروع الطموح الذي
يعد بحقبه حضاريه جديده يمكن للناس من
مختلف التنوعات الثقافيه ان يبنوا فيها
عالما مشتركا ينعم بالسلام والازدهار
والثراء الثقافي في قلب الجزيره العربيه
كنت اتابع اعلان نيوم وكان حولي طالبات
وطلاب جورج تاون وهم ياتون من تنوعات
ثقافيه هائله فبدا لي ان هناك رابطا بين
هذا التنوع والتنوع الذي تعد به نيوم ولكن
من جانب اخر ولكون بعض هؤلاء الطلاب كنت
قد التقيتهم بالفعل في صف دراسي او اكثر
من صفوف الثقافه العربيه التي حظيت بفرصه
تدريسها في جورج تاون منذ عام 2014 لم يكن
بوسعه حقيقه الا ان اتذكر بعضا من الاسئله
المتكرره لهؤلاء الطلاب الاذكياء حول
بلادي هؤلاء الطلاب ياتون من تخصصات
العلاقات الدوليه والسياسات الخارجيه
وبعضهم يتخصص في الدراسات العربيه
والاسلاميه ودراسات الشرق الاوسط ومع ذلك
كنت افاجا باسئله من قبيل هل يسمح بتداول
كتب الفلسفه والادب الحديث لديكم في
السعوديه هل هناك فن سعودي حديث ومعاصر هل
هناك مفكرون سعوديون كيف استطعت ان تكتب
رساله الماجستير عن شاعر مثل المتنبي
بينما شعره لا يتفق مع النظام الاخلاقي
لديكم في السعوديه
وبالتاكيد معظم هذه الاسئله كانت تدور حول
الموضوع المفضل لدى كثيرين وهو موضوع
المراه السعوديه الذي لحسن الحظ كان قد
خسر مؤخرا سؤال المليون دولار لماذا لا
تقود المراه السعوديه السياره
[تصفيق]
قد تبدو لنا هذه الاسئله غريبه نوعا ما
كما انها تخالف الواقع وهي بالتاكيد اسئله
لا تنتمي الى المستقبل الذي تعد به نيوم
ورؤيه السعوديه عشرين ثلاثين ومع ذلك فهي
اسئله مفهومه تماما في سياقها
فهناك
صوره نمطيه سطحيه او سرديه
اختزاليه وتبسيطيه وجوهرانيه لثقافه
الجزيره العربيه نتيجه
لعوامل كثيره جدا من اهمها غياب محتوى
علمي رصين عن التداول الاكاديمي في
الاكاديميه الغربيه عن ثقافه الجزيره
العربيه والخليج والمملكه ومن هنا يتخرج
بعض طلاب هذه الاقسام المتخصصه وهم ينقصهم
الكثير من المعرفه عن ثقافه هذا الجزء
من العالم فيما بعد هؤلاء الخريجين
يتبؤون مناصب مهمه
كمستشارين في سياسات الشرق الاوسط وتبقى
تلك الصوره السطحيه تتحرك في الخلفيه
لتؤثر في كيفيه النظر الى دول المنطقه وفي
كيفيه صنع السياسات
للتعامل معها ومن هنا يعاد تدوير هذه
الصوره السطحيه
وتتكرر المشكله التي اشتكى منها الاديب
السعودي والدبلوماسي المعروف غازي القصيبي
حينما قال نفط يقول الناس عن وطني ما
انصفوا وطني هو المجد
في الحقيقه لطالما واجهت مشكلات كتلك التي
اشتكى منها غاز القصيبي منذ ان ذهبت الى
الولايات المتحده في عام 2010 فتخصصي هو
الدراسات الشرقيه والدراسات العربيه
والاسلاميه وما يمكن تسميته بالسؤال
السعودي هو جزء اساسي من النقاشات في هذه
التخصصات وفي يوم اطلاق نيوم كنت اقول في
نفسي انه لامر يستحق التامل ان نقارن بين
هذه السوره النمطيه السطحيه وبين سرديه
المستقبل الجديد الذي تعد به نيوم والذي
نراه يتخلق امامنا يوميا بفعل المبادرات
المتنوعه والثقافيه تحديدا لرؤيه السعوديه
عشرين ثلاثين التي تبشر بمستقبل واعد
للمنطقه وتحث على الاعتزاز بالهويه
الثقافيه مع بناء جسور التواصل
مع العالم
ومن هنا وللاسهام في بناء هذه الجسور فقد
حرصت
تحديدا في جورج تاون على تقديم المواد
الابداعيه لابناء المنطقه الى المجتمع
الاكاديمي هناك وساضرب مثالا واحدا على
ذلك ففي ربيع عام 2018 حظيت بفرصه تدريس
ماده الادب العربي الحديث هناك وانضم
اليها طلاب بكالوريوس وماجستير ودكتوراه
من تخصصات متنوعه
وكانت فرصه رائعه لتقديم المواد الابداعيه
لابناء المنطقه
لهؤلاء الطلاب والاستضافه بعض هؤلاء
المبدعين لدينا في هذا الصف الدراسي
للحديث بشكل مباشر مع الطلاب كان هذا
النقاش يزيد من مساحه المعرفه بثقافه
الجزيره العربيه
ويؤدي الى تكوين فهم ادق عن ثقافه هذا
الجزء الثري ابداعيا من العالم الشهر
الاخير من هذا الفصل الدراسي خصصته لواحد
من اهم شعراء المفضلين وهو الشاعر السعودي
محمد الثباتي
واعتقد ان تخصيصي هذا الشهر الثدي هو نوع
من انواع التحيز الحميد الذي اصبت به في
ذلك الوقت قرا الطلاب نصوص الثبيتي
التاسيسيه في التضاريس وموقف الرمال موقف
الجناس ولكم ان تتخيلوا ان طلابا يدرسون
الادب العربي لاول مره
حفظوا مقاطع من شعر الثباتي وقراوا بتعمق
في الحاله الثقافيه السعوديه بشكل عام
واذكر اننا في الاسبوع الاخير خرجنا الى
الساحه الخارجيه له فاميلي ستورنسور التي
تطل على نهر في واشنطن وطلب احد الطلاب ان
يلقي مقطعا حفظه من قصيده موقف الرمال
موقف الجناس لمحمد الثبيتي فقام يلقي
امامنا المقطع الشهير قال يا ايها
النخل
يغتابك الشجر الهزيل
ويذمك الوتد الذليل وتظل تسمو في فضاء
الله ذا ثمر خرافي ولا صبر جميل
في الحقيقه لم يكن طلابي في جورج تاون هم
وحدهم من راوا في ذلك المقطع امرا خاصا
فعلى مشارف نهايه هذا الصف الدراسي
وتحديدا في ثلاثه مايو 2018 نشر الحساب
الرسمي لوزاره الخارجيه السعوديه في تويتر
تغريده يشيد فيها بمحمد الثبيتي كحد ابرز
اقطاب الحداثه الادبيه في العالم العربي
وماذا كان المقطع الذي اختارته هذه
الوزاره التي تتمثل مهمتها في بناء جسور
التواصل مع العالم لم يكن الا مقطع النخل
الذي يسمو في فضاء الله ذا ثمر خرافي وذا
صبر جميل
قوبلت هذه التغريده بحماس كبير جدا وقراها
بعضهم كاشاره رمزيه على التحول الثقافي
الهائل الذي تشهده المملكه بفعل مبادرات
رؤيه السعوديه
عشرين ثلاثين ولم يطول الامر حقيقه لكي
ينتقل هذا التحول من شكله الرمزي في هذه
التغريده الى الشكل المؤسساتي فبعد شهر
واحد فقط من هذه التغريده اعلن عن انشاء
اول وزاره متخصصه للثقافه في تاريخ البلاد
وبعد ذلك باشهر اطلقت الاستراتيجيه
الوطنيه للثقافه لتكون
المحرك الذي يقود هذا التحول الثقافي نحو
بيئه ثقافيه تنبض بالحياه وتزدهر فيها
الفنون
وتربط الامه السعوديه الشابه بتقاليدها
التراثيه الغنيه والعميقه حينها ايقنت بان
العالم سيشهد عما قريب حقبه جديده من
التنوير الثقافي تنطلق هذه المره من قلب
الجزيره العربيه حيث ولدت اللغه والثقافه
العربيه والمعلقات العشر ونزل الوحي
القراني العربي المبين منذ مئات السنين
بعد ذلك باشهر وفقت لمناقشه رساله
الدكتوره وكان الادب السعودي جزءا اساسيا
فيها ثم عدت الى المملكه لاشهد بشكل مباشر
هذا التحول الثقافي ومنذ عوده حظيت بفرصه
الاستمتاع بما يمكن ان تقدمه الثقافه
السعوديه لمواطنيها وزائريها وللعالم اجمع
وزاد يقيني بقدره الاعمال الابداعيه على
بناء الجسور الثقافيه فعبر تعزيز هذه
الروابط بين الشرق والغرب تتخلق دائما فرص
ابداعيه جديده وينشا فهم
عالمي اكثر دقه عن امه سعوديه حديثه
جذورها التاريخيه راسخه وثقافتها المعاصره
مزدهره وبناتها وابنائها شركاء في جعل
العالم مكانا افضل
واخيرا اليوم بينما اتنقل في شوارع جده
والرياض والدمام والعلا وجزان والباحه
وابها وحائل والمدينه ومكه
اتذكر ذلك المستقبل الذي
وعد وعد به اعلان اطلاقي نيوم واجدوا حولي
لافتات الاحتفاء بعام الشعر العربي
وبالمهرجانات الثقافيه المتنوعه فارفع
بصري الى السماء وتذكروا باندهاش قول محمد
الثباتي وهو يحتفي بتضاريس البلاد
المتنوعه
وباولئك الناظرين الى الامام الناظرين الى
المستقبل وهو يقول ونظرت في عين السماء
فخذت شرارات الظما
وانشق عن مطر غمام
للبائثين على الطوى
والناشرين لمن طوى
والناظرين الى الامام
للنخل
للكثبان
للشيح الشمالي
وللنفحات من ريح الصبا
للطير في خضر الربا للشمس
للجبل الحجازي
وللبحر اتهامي شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]